hey guys dregg here John here we're
gonna watch the trailer for a movie
called wish upon oh no think about it
yeah well I haven't actually seen it but
we ran this trailer on the site yeah
blue house calm where I do the social
media also social media for the Rio
rejects reason is Jerry Twitter
Instagram Greg Alva here we go I went
what context does he just like go right
you saw that it's given me everything
money love whoa at what car
ah
whoa Wow whoa whoa I had no idea what to
expect was that that was brutal
that's a sinister contest right there I
think the concept is really excellent I
think that excellent concept an evil
story about wishing me and like the
granted wishes and then you just like
the fucked-up version of the monkeys
policy or ads like you're wishing for
[ __ ] stuff and it gets [ __ ] up as
it happened the fucked-up stuff she's
wishing for looks [ __ ] up yeah I wish
you then that girl's rotting [ __ ]
deserved it don't kill the controller on
the bike I'm driving here
[ __ ] [ __ ] I hope you brought up the
actress died I hope anyone lied it is at
its very good this is a fantasy soon oh
man if it was real [ __ ] she'd be dead
so many people will be dead I would be
very proud out of wishes a
fringle heard myself oh yeah seven
wishes and you can't kill somebody I
mean that's just poor with poor wishing
oh yeah they're a bad genie it doesn't
matter how hard you work if you don't
work smart brother okay concept is cool
yeah I'm not entirely sold on full movie
execution grant just a minute in
nineteen seconds but some of the ways
shot and some of the way the acting was
done looked a little bit like this could
feel a little cliche in the way how
things might unfold or acne might not be
fully there but the concept is cooling
up yet me really intrigued for sure it's
that time of the year I think where
you're seeing like cool trailers for
stuff that might be cool and I don't
know yeah it's like I also saw this in
my concern from the trailer at least was
and it's not a big concern maybe the
movie will clear this right up but it
seems like the second she makes that
wish seems like she learns oh yeah this
is probably a bad idea yeah and it
seemed like there's going to be more you
know requests made of that magic box so
I'm curious as to whether it's just
going to be her doing all this or if
it's going to be like it falls in the
wrong hands or whatever so a little
unclear as to like if this is all coming
from one person who's not learning very
well or if it's you know bigger than
maybe she can wish that it all gets
reversed yeah maybe or maybe she can
wish for infinite wishes ooh
I don't know why no one in these wish
movies does that I think he's Marcus
wish I think we was master Aladdin now
this [ __ ] that's the smartest wish you
could do it would be I think I think
people have finally at least in more
recently wish stuff they'll go write
that into the rule like you can't ask
for more wishes very smart so he's
mentioning you can't do it is a child
all right guys what would you wish for a
pony the Jew a pony you ponies you that
grin to infinite wishes the grant
sorenson subscribe to the real rejects
generally told you he's on any social
reasons to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram I'm sorry I thought we were
doing that at the top now last couple
videos got confused or I wish that you
would shut the [ __ ] up say some hmm my
wish came true